when it comes to the perfect football
meal the beast has you covered cisco who
is sponsoring this segment has brought
the crew in from the beast by todd
english to tell us more welcome
executive chef sani and pitmaster orel
welcome you guys thank you welcome great
to be here you brought some food in
where can we find this food where's the
restaurant located uh restaurants
located in the middle of area 15. we are
a part of their entire complex so
it's a great big art and entertainment
complex
lots of things to do there but make sure
to stop by the beast to get some of this
great food that we do out here where
okay let's start with some of the some
of the food you brought here what kind
of chicken wings are up there sure so we
have multiple wings at the restaurant we
brought we have two over here we're
gonna do the third one together
i have a peanut butter and jelly wing
first up over here oh i heard about
those that's rocky's favorite there you
go so it's a it's a guava glaze with a
thai peanut sauce our traditional
buffalo wings but as you can see all our
wings are flying they we don't uh we
don't just let them sit down you know we
make sure that they're uh still in the
air yeah they're in flight so we're
gonna make some wings today which one's
gonna be we're gonna we're gonna do the
korean style chicken wings here so uh
what we got going on here is a
traditional korean style sauce that we
tweak a little bit on our end just to do
it uh start off with a little a quarter
stick of butter there some butter yep
we'll melt the butter and then we don't
count calories at the beast do we no
absolutely not yeah right oh well we
don't count calories no this whole thing
is going absolutely put some butter in
there sure absolutely melt that up we're
gonna throw in the all the other sauces
okay much once that butter comes down we
have a little ginger and garlic we add
to that i love it full of flavor
absolutely so
it's it's really just what we do there
is is more like a test kitchen we just
play around with food all day and we've
come up with some really interesting
things as you can see here this is just
the tip of the iceberg if you will
what's the name of the beast where does
that come beast
just the size of the kitchen it's huge
we have an enormous kitchen and we do a
lot of different foods we we missed one
here we have the brisket over here that
we do yes so pit master oil is really in
charge of our uh of all our smoked
products um we do ribs we do brisket we
do pastrami in-house pastrami um is it
your favorite the pit master oh how long
does it take how long has that been
smoking for anywhere from 12 to 14 hours
ooh and you don't put any sauce on it
you're a rubber you put rub on it yeah
salt pepper cayenne goes sauce on on
something like that is hiding something
you put the rub on there right exactly
you want to get it how it is right do
you want to cut that up over there let's
get it going start slicing up and i'm
making wings this is how we do it at the
beast and what's this what do we have
here on top of the table oh just some of
our intricate items that we do at the
you know we because we are the beasts so
our cow skull you know we also our theme
is really uh it's it's mad max
meets uh burning man so it's really uh
it's really an art project you know that
we're doing look at my is my sauce done
absolutely
i think my sauce needs some work it
hasn't really
it hasn't really um
melted yet desserts tell me about these
desserts before i wrap things up awesome
absolutely so our our pastry chef put
these together and we have a big a
cookie that we serve over there it's it
is really large
this thing is a frisbee look at the size
of this cookie you guys this thing is
huge look how big that cookie is this is
a frisbee it's not a cookie that is one
our big a cookie as i
said um
we have a peanut butter cup so it's a
reese's peanut butter style cup parfait
style uh carrot cake oreo cheesecake
apple pie new cheese cannolis resource
world it's an easy place to get into it
really is if someone's watching yeah
sorry area 15. i got a resort swirl on
my mind for the last segment area 15 is
easy to stop in and get to can we pop in
there and buy this stuff to go like the
desserts absolutely we can do desserts
all desserts go our entire menu to go
anything that you'd like
area 15 is it is it's free to get in um
and there's multiple things to do once
you're inside of there you know it's
it's a lot of fun anyway let's finish up
these wings i brought k-wing sauce with
us okay put the sauce in there and i'm
gonna grab some of this meat over here
part of my reach over here i gotta try
this meat here this looks it's so cheesy
whoa
oh well
there's a spot on my man
this is delicious
we'll take those wings during the break
we've got to wrap it up
absolutely absolutely no no problem this
is fantastic the beast over area 15. you
guys this is amazing open seven days a
week yes sir seven days a week 12 to 12
with the restaurant the area 15 is open
later thank you guys and thank you to
cisco for sponsoring this segment check
out the beast at area 15 give them a
call
at 725-210-5365
or visit area 15.com this meet is so
good you guys thank you so much